alors merci cela soit calme et évita
satellite sens bien ici un voisin que
c'est ma place naturelle en vrai ouais
je prends tout tapas la durée j'aurais
plus derrière les groupes utilisent vrai
je reste quelques minutes je fais dès
que les l'audience je fait décoller
l'a380 et après je vous laisse piloter
on va prendre le thé coeur on va compter
gars on va prendre on va prendre les
actions monsieur sur monsieur bonnet
monsieur bonnet monsieur vous à la place
de gilles ça j'aime beaucoup ça ça va ça
va être bon alors on va vous équipez
vous allez voir comme gilles verdez je
vais vous donner un mini ça vient nous
dire quand vous appelez pas merci un peu
ça fait plaisir de voir gérard louvin ça
fait longtemps qu à ce jour quel est
votre prénom didier didier bonsoir vous
faites quoi dans la vie didier retraite
dit j'ai l'impression que tu me manques
je vous met une oreillette didier est ce
que je peux vous mettre ça dans
l'orifice oui ça va ça fait pas trop mal
merci didier vous êtes content d'être
avec nous ouais il serait pas je peux
vous faire un petit bisou
oui merci de plaisir merci merci d'être
là merci vous est donné avec qui elle
est droite fin de votre fille vous savez
que vous allez devoir dire tout ce que
vous dit gilles verdez donc a priori
vous repartirez sur votre fameux sans
votre je peux vous dire pour les avoir
vus ou alors ils sont dix d'avoir un
oscar
ils ont pas joué du tout la comédie et
ils s'entendent très bien
didier louis moreau vous n'êtes pas
crédible c'est pour télé 7 jours
[Rires]
un coach il ya un autre coach ou alors
une histoire d'amour entre un candidat
et un coach c'est toujours pareil quoi
toujours pareil capucine [ __ ] ferme ta
gueule
[Applaudissements]
au moins il n'en sera rien à l'émission
et je ne vois pas ce qu'il apporte enfin
il apporterait rien en plus par rapport
aux jurés actuelle rien dieu était mort
on voit attaquer mr discovery et fait
nouveau pour attaquer mr gibbs en
malaisie que je voulais
[Rires]
sur ces trois quarts des fans abc perdre
la piscine adaptée et qui sont comme rue
bersot mise à bas si je crois
aujourd'hui
eh ben il ya eu il ya une vie à notre
humeur et pas que vous deviez acheter un
livre ses parents étaient choqués sont
montés sur parier comment ça décidément
tf1 il prenait que des bonnes décisions
il trouve qu'ils rentrent pas
effectivement un petit peu dans le
cahier des charges très bons ils disent
n'importe quoi une fois confiant et je
t'aime mais qu'est ce qu'un atout pas
tout
la musique trouve ça très bien je trouve
qu'effectivement la programmation de
cette émission est beaucoup trop tardive
mais si elle n'était plus là dans tpm
paix ça me manquerait beaucoup parce que
c'est une chronique heures hors pair une
chronique une guerre religieuse
et si l'eau au niveau du français ont
des commandes merci didier
qu'est-ce qui est cheikh mourou ce soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
évidemment qu'elle a un avenir en tant
qu'animatrice elle l'a très bien fait
quand elle vous remplace de temps en
temps le vendredi elle le fait super
bien derrière le poste je suis jeune
j'étais la première devant ses émissions
là je trouve ça très dommage que ce soit
que ça se soit arrêtée après c'est vrai
que elle est hyper bonne en tant que
chroniqueuse sûreté pmp si elle part ça
va beaucoup manquer quand elle n'est pas
là en chroniqueuse je trouve que je
trouve qu'elle manque parce que elle dit
ce qu'elle pensait des caches et la
vraie question c'est est ce que les gens
ont envie de dieu aurait de fer langue
de bois et ta copine il vous
rappelleront très vite didier vous avez
quelque chose à dire a ajouté je crois
enora j'adore moi aussi je t'adore
didier gilles bernard d'ormale ligue 1
mon gars parlent les autres vous êtes
une bonne dose remarquent
[Applaudissements]
il attendit la première fois les autres
vous êtes une bande de renards vous dire
pour non mais quoi du personnage